is why men
most men always get looked upon like
like they're not a hoe why is it
different for women than it is for men
because men and women are different they
are because they are because it's easy
for us to get sex the world doesn't like
think highly of you if you do what's
easy and men getting sex is hard so if
they do what's hard it's valued if we do
what's easy it's not
so for you for example for you um as a
lady you're very pretty um attractive
thank you
um black woman and and on Instagram I've
never seen an Instagram but I'm sure if
you put on your Instagram every single
day that um you you was lonely and you
wanted some company I'm sure you
wouldn't have any problems with people
messaging you or if you asked you ask
the people to take you out but if one of
us did that and said that we wanted sex
we would probably have our Instagram
shut down now the difference with us is
okay if if if in order for me to sleep
with 100 women
um especially quality beautiful women I
would have to have some type of value
about myself in order for you to sleep
over 100 men you don't have to do
anything but just say it and you can
just walk down the road and you would
find men that will sleep with you
um so that's why but what about men that
lie what about men okay for example I'm
a pretty girl if I do say I'm lonely on
my Instagram and somebody does come or
approach me in a way where like they're
coming across as they're good and then
they've lied to me or made me feel like
they were going to do something good in
my life and in the it turned out that it
wasn't that all I ended up giving myself
to somebody and now they're like yeah I
don't want to do you anymore so now
that's added on a number to the previous
guys that I've done before and it comes
across the I'm a home and realistically
that wasn't the situation yeah it's like
how many times are you gonna get
bamboozled what like I think most guys
like okay so like if I'm at home too
they're like all right but like when
you're like 20 30. all of them wherever
my hopeless romantic no you may you make
bad decisions so why does it necessary
to be bad because you've slept with 10
or how many people and nothing's come of
it so for me as a man all those 10
previous men you slept with they don't
add anything to me they're just men that
have used you and now left you for me so
what you've been better of you doing is
is is vetting those guys better your job
as a woman is to vet the [ __ ] that
is not our job you need to mitigate
these men that come into your life and
say right which one is is he serious
he's not serious if you give up the
goods every single time a guy takes your
number takes you out for something to
eat that's up to you because they're the
ones that lie though no but this is also
up to you because you you have to you
have to differentiate between the men
that lying the men which don't lie if
you cannot um separate the good men from
the bad men whose fault is that that's
not General sometimes it's kind of hard
to tell We're not gonna like sit here
and be like I think that's that's
[ __ ] come on that's [ __ ] you
know as a girl as a girl you you know
deep down you just you're just trying to
sell you you just want to change them I
hate you you don't let him down which
guys in a room you walk into you knew
which ones are getting laid you know
which ones aren't but they love it
anyway
but the thing is like we want the guys
that get laid we don't want this no one
else wants not necessarily what if I'm
not trying to get laid what if it's a
thing where I'm literally trying to know
you as a person do you want to date
someone that no one else wants to date
no girls love the bathroom I kind of do
though I don't know so you just said it
yourself so you go so you're going for
guys that you already know that a lot of
women want so these are these are men
that are obviously they wanna they they
high value in a sense a lot of women
want them whenever you go for these
types of men you have to understand you
you are just one you could potentially
be one of many and you don't want you
don't like being you don't mind being
one of many there's probably some guys
across the years that I've always
probably tried to holler at you tried to
take you out and you haven't given any
time to These Guys these ordinary
ordinary I don't know but it's fine but
what I'm trying to say all of these guys
have watched you deal with all these
guys one by one one by one and it never
amounts to nothing at some point you
need to say to yourself maybe I am going
for the wrong types of guy maybe this
guy's not right for me maybe I need to
stop going for what I like and maybe I
need to start going for what makes sense
but this is the thing with females I
think I feel like they don't get to that
stage until they're maybe more mature
like I feel like
um
want them that's what happens then their
options start narrowing that's when they
start being a bit more pragmatic about
what guy makes sense yeah until then so
you've told what 35 for geriatric
pregnancy so it's like and unless you
have twenty thousand dollars to put down
and maybe get a kid out of it maybe like
you gotta you at like 30 I feel like
people start getting desperate I feel
like when females get to the age of 30
that's when they start looking at the
guys around them and they'll be like you
know what I'm tired of being abused or
tired of going through the same old
story so you know what now I might go
for the good guy that may not have
wanted me beforehand I feel like the
modern the modern day kind of girls are
a bit different though not necessarily
it doesn't necessarily mean that they're
looking for a child or another husband
sometimes they're literally trying to
get their money build their next
generation for it doesn't necessarily
have to mean a child that comes from
them they could adopt they can do other
options it's not just you can't they can
but the least happy demographic of women
is women over the ages of 45 that make
between I think it's like
between 50 to like seventy thousand
dollars per year and are single and
childless like life got pretty good
about it though what are they bothered
about me yeah they're the least happy
demographic like life gets pretty lonely
after the age of 45 like right you know
I don't think as women we really
understand how different the world
treats us because we're pretty women
and and because one day your looks are
going to be gone you're gonna get no
attention from men like 40 40 to no no
men are lining up to date 50 year olds
it's a good thing I got personality then
isn't it that won't work that won't work
do you do you care about a girl if a
girl doesn't look good do you care about
a personality of course not yeah well
you guys if you're trying to wife
someone why would you not care about
their family no I said if she I I'm
careful with my words if she doesn't
look good you have to start with looks
not necessarily yeah for women you're
looking at it from a female point of
view for the men it's it's it starts
with looks it starts with sex so you
have to understand something before you
try to speak you have to understand and
accept what we're saying to you it's
lots of looks it does it does it does
because before I before you I even come
and get your number or you want to speak
to you I've assess the way you look so
if you if I didn't like the way you look
why would I come and speak to you in
order for me to know your personality
that will involve us having to work
together or be in a scenario where we
can speak enough for me to know your
personality if a guy comes up to you out
of the blue try to speak to you are you
gonna oh my God he's got such a handsome
personality you don't know his
personality all you know is the guy
that's approaching you and whether or
not you want to accept his approach or
not listen to him or just give him air
so you also you you so your first
attraction is based upon in that aspect
in a nightclub or outside setting based
upon attraction because you don't know
what the personal personality is and for
females I feel like a guy has to give a
certain image before you even take him
into consideration
someone had you but no that's just the
reality of it like for me I'm a short
guy I'm five foot four for me if I
approach a girl in a club I'm not likely
to get the same reception that my
brother would over there because he's
taller than me and he's more built do
you get me I'm short and I'm small so
it's like it's gonna be harder for a man
like me to move to a girl because she's
gonna look at me and be like that's not
really my type she won't even give me
the initial
black
I don't know they're an issue but you
see my brother here you see that type of
um that blatant look you just assess
yourself and you said right these are my
strength this is whatever men we have no
problem in doing that do you understand
we can look at another guy and say right
this guy is this is you um in comparison
to me or whatever his strengths are my
weaknesses or my strengths and his
weaknesses right women will look at
themselves and they won't do that same
assessment and it's that little bit of
um you have to have humility and
humbleness and and you'll get better
results but us man we can do that
I feel like women can too everyone was a
says they turn
I feel like there's a little animosity
against women here okay sorry bro can I
just say something okay so before I want
to tell you a little bit about me I have
three sisters
um they're all married all with child my
mum and dad are together maybe together
for over 40 years
um I come from an African traditional
upbringing my dad is the chief of all
chiefs he was a diplomat very educated
man I have three nieces
um that are all directly look after when
it comes to women I'm a protector I'm a
love of my women so we take quite we
take it quite insulting when a woman
says oh we feel as if that you're any
type of hate towards women because
having a criticism or no but what I'm
trying any type of animosity or anything
that's not what we're here for what
we're here for is to show how much love
we have for women in actual fact we need
to have these conversations so I take it
quite personally when people try to
create that image or perpetuate that
image because if you don't know I'm
actually a very much support of women
and we protect all women over here so I
just had to say that
did you know that women find 80 percent
of men is unattractive
I didn't know that so A Lot have you
ever heard the girl say like medium ugly
like oh I gave him a chance he was
medium ugly I say cute ugly yeah it's
like it's hypnosis that's just your
level
[Laughter]
50 of Menace men is attractive and the
question is if you find a guy attractive
he's probably the top 20 percent of men
are you top 20 of women and that's what
we have nowaday and you can get this
data from dating apps because women only
swipe right between five and like 20 of
the time and if you ask 100 of women
what they want in a man they list 20 of
men
um
that's where you have eternal like side
chicks basically
[Laughter]
back and we monetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible